i have absolutely huge breaking news for
you
one of the biggest stories out there new
details have emerged
about hunter biden's laptop emails
just kidding i'm not an idiot but over
the memorial day holiday
fox news really did pretend to break
this explosive story about a conspiracy
theory related to the president's
son who has nothing to do with his
administration whatsoever check this out
it was maybe not surprisingly
on fox and friends here we go
[Music]
new details emerging in the hunter biden
scandal email reportedly
show a meeting between his then vice
president father joe biden
and hunter's business partners from
around the world
yes so we must have had a lot of
translators there and two separate
dinners that are chronicled in his
laptop as it becomes leaked out more and
more todd pyro joins us live
as the plot thickens and his dad's
presence as vice president
very present can you believe that guys
now
if you were paying attention all along
you'd know that they
already did this supposed exclusive in
october of 2020. it's now
seven or eight months old when fox
reported
about quote hunter's ex-partner recounts
meeting joe biden claims family paranoid
about hiding former vp's involvement it
was a non-story outside
of the fox news max conspiracy universe
because there was no actual evidence of
anything untoward happening
it's sort of not shocking that if it's
true that joe biden met people that his
son worked with
that that would that would be something
that takes place and and
this is what they cheered on about trump
trump made deals and his kids are
involved and everybody's so good at
business and trump helps his kids and
isn't everybody so great at everything
but now if indeed it happened with joe
biden
then it's definitely bad it's definitely
very very bad
let's look at a little bit more of this
from the fox and friends report
and there's two separate meetings there
uh thanks todd how does he explain the
email
of one of the guys at that dinner
thanking him an executive from burisma
thanking hunter biden for introducing
him to his dad we get details
it's in the new york post today miranda
devine's got a book that's coming out in
september it's called laptop from hell
what's really curious okay now did you
see what steve ducey did there
this is a really important propaganda
technique to understand
you know how sometimes fox news will
insert opinion into news shows by
reporting on what tucker said the night
before
and then they react to what tucker said
during the opinion show
as if it's news that tucker said it
that's one technique fox uses to blur
the lines
between opinion and use reporting the
new york post has now run multiple
discredited stories on the hunter
biden laptop and the new york post is
owned by news corporation which also
owns fox news
so remember this the first hunter
biden story back in october was
published despite
fox news saying we're not going to touch
it and even
some reporters at the new york post
saying we really shouldn't publish this
crap
it was widely reported on including by
the new york times as we're putting up
on the screen for you
and at the time fox did the same they
reported on
the new york post story in order to be
able to talk about it
without running the report themselves
which they said we can't run this this
is trash
fox decided let's just run the fact that
the new york post
reported on it and then that allowed
them to do a week of coverage
here it's basically the same thing steve
ducey holding up
the newspaper from the new york post
with the story so of course with this
new article
we'll see whether the claims are even
true
but remember that the track record from
the post on these stories is highlighted
by a salon article from october
fox news rejected hunter biden
expose new york post writer
refused to put his name on it
but then fox news did weeks of coverage
based on the very new york post
reporting that fox news said
we can't actually run this this is no
good this is how they do it this is a
technique you have to understand
and it's important that as a savvy media
consumer that we should all aspire to be
to be we not only identify the
difference between
this is a news report and this is
opinion and of course they deliberately
blur that to make it difficult
but we also are able to distinguish this
is a
news report based on a confirmed news
report or
this is a news report based on something
that is essentially gossip
um and that's an important distinction
to be able to make as well
so we'll have more on this on our
instagram make sure you're following us
on instagram at davidpakmanshow
and while you're at it follow me on
instagram at david.pacman
new backyard garden tour
some people get mad someone wrote to me
saying david how dare you show us those
disgusting stink weeds in your backyard
most people liked it though so there
will be a new garden tour on my
instagram
david.pakman one of our sponsors is
four sigmatic the company best known for
their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee
with both lion's mane and chaga
mushrooms chaga mushrooms have actually
been shown to have potential in
supporting the immune system in
peer-reviewed studies
i've been drinking four sigmatic coffee
a lot lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any
delicious coffee but it's really easy on
my stomach doesn't give me any jittery
feeling
or a midday crash and they have over 20
000 5 star reviews and best of all
if you don't love it you'll get 100
percent of your money back because
they stand behind their product you've
got nothing to lose by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to forty percent off
and free shipping when you go to four
sigmatic dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video